Hello psyched to go errs. We just want to take the time to thank you for all your kind support. We're a team of dedicated
Passionate and hardworking individuals who come together every day with one goal in mind
We want to make psychology come alive for you
We are self-funded and recently launched our patreon if you enjoy the work we do and find it meaningful
Please stick around until the end of the video for information on how to get more involved with us and all the cool
Rewards you can get from us. We hope you enjoy this video
Have you been going on dates and wondering whether you should start a relationship or maybe you just moved because you got a new job
You're going to school since you don't know anyone and want to build connections. You might be asking yourself
Should I date and seek a relationship due to social norms?
We may often feel pressured to date when we're single but entering a relationship is a huge commitment
Have you been reluctant to try but not sure why?
Here are seven signs. You may not be ready for a relationship
One you care more about finding the perfect partner instead of working on yourself
Are you constantly daydreaming about finding your prince charming or Cinderella when you're walking down the streets and see many couples holding?
Hands or listening to love songs as you're waiting for the bus
It's normal to think about who your ideal soulmate is
Love is exciting when you meet someone you share chemistry with but relationships always
require work in order to survive getting butterflies in your stomach isn't
ultimate love
Sometimes Prince Charming or Cinderella will let you down and it won't be perfect
Don't spend all your time and energy finding someone who meets every requirement on your list instead
Work on being the best version of yourself
- you're still working on your goals and discovering who you are
Do you want to travel and see more of the world or join programs that help you turn your hobbies into potential careers?
There's nothing wrong with doing you. In fact soul searching is an incredibly morning experience
That's when you get to reflect form connections with great people and do more of what makes you happy
3 you want someone to save you?
it's not romantic to have someone save you from your problems or
misery if you're unhappy or want an easy way out of your problems a
Relationship is not the answer. You can't expect someone to be your hero or stop the hurt from hurting
It's dangerous to use relationships to distract yourself from your problems
In fact, this can even attract toxic partners who feed off of codependent behavior
Live your life actively and don't wait for someone to show up if you need help that's normal and healthy
Surround yourself with supportive people who can be there for you on bad days
For you want to save someone else?
You can't change or fix someone's damage when you want to rescue someone from their bad habits
You will consider them more as a project
Instead of someone you want to be in a relationship with although it was possible to fall in love with someone you want to save
this doesn't create the best or healthiest relationships trying to change someone who meets your
Expectations will only leave you with disappointment
Everyone has the capability to change
But through their own will and at their own pace
5 you still frequently think and talk about your ex. You can't control when or who you meet
That's why life works in mysterious ways
Unfortunately, that's how timing can sometimes be off
Just when you think you're ready to be in a relationship with someone they may still be
recovering from heartbreak and hung up on their ex or vice versa
If you're having a hard time recovering check out our video 5 ways to deal with a breakup
6 you have a hard time
Apologizing or admitting when you're wrong
There's one word that describes whatever relationship needs
Compromise if you have a habit of thinking you're always right and would rather hold on to your ego instead of making things
Right, and you may want to hold off entering a relationship?
focus first on learning how to own up to your mistakes
reflect as often as you can and become more self-aware about the decisions you make
Everything has a consequence
7 you're emotionally closed off
If you have a tendency to keep your walls up
Then you may want to work on being vulnerable first practice with your friends and family or a therapist being in a relationship
Means allowing someone to see you for all that you are it's the only way for someone to love you, honestly
but if you have a habit of holding back
You must work through your fears and Trust issues before committing to someone a healthy relationship
Is about two people being able to take risks and grow together
Do you feel uncertain about dating or beginning a relationship, please? Share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych to go and check out our patreon
we started it because we want to grow into a bigger platform that reaches more people who are in need of help with your
contribution
You can receive our psi pendant t-shirt issues of our magazine and many more membership benefits
Your funding will help us produce quality script writing voice overs an animation that makes our content both entertaining and educational
We want to make sure our community members get the best and only the best. Thanks for watching
Hey everybody
I just want to give a personal thank-you video for you guys for always supporting site to go and making this all possible
For us our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible so that it promotes self awareness and it helps you guys grow
however
We want to make more content for you guys and would love your support and buying one of these bracelets from our partner
Intergroup Alice check out the bracelet. It's pretty cool
And it even includes
Pluto the link to purchase will all be in the description below and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye
You